okay this is uh
this is an instructional or tutorial
video on how
the new feature in pepper panic saga the
grills
these things right here work in the game
it was nice to see this in the last
update because we hadn't seen any new
features for quite a while
and um i think in general these are a
little bit harder to
or a little bit harder to understand
immediately how they worked
so we're going to go through and talk
about what they do how you can use them
and uh just how they change the game
in general so there's two things that
these grills do
all the peppers that are sitting on
grills are basically connected
okay so we have four yellow peppers over
here that are away from all the rest
that are sitting on top of grills and if
we explode
a yellow pepper on one of these over
here it'll do
the first thing that they do which is
it'll grow each of these peppers
when it explodes instead of growing at
just one
stage like it would for a regular
explosion it will
it'll give um it'll grow it to two so a
stage one pepper will turn into a stage
three pepper
and that'll get you closer to exploding
these
the other way that it works and it's not
really
as much of a factor on this um level
but when you when you create a shock
wave that passes over
peppers that are sitting on the grates
they'll also grow by an extra stage
all right so i i pulled up a couple of
my videos from
the um our last you know our lot you
know our last
batch of uh level videos for the last
episode so i'll show you how this works
a little bit
better okay so here we have
level 386 all right and
this one starts out it's the very first
uh great or
grills level and it starts out with a
match that's already set up for you
that'll make an explosion
and one thing to notice about this
is that all the reds are in place
they're on the grill so
whenever we make this match in here
and we're going to be matching
let's see
we're going to be matching
three stage twos which normally wouldn't
give us an explosion okay
usually if the number of dots adds up to
six or below it won't create an
explosion but seven plus
will so that shows us right away that
the grills also
accelerate the matches that we make
over top of them so we're going to make
a
we're going to make a match that will
explode
because it's sitting on a grill and then
we'll see that all these stage one
reds on the outside will grow to stage
threes
instead of just stage two so go ahead
and we'll watch this
all right so you can see that we made
our explosion
and all the peppers sitting on grills of
the same color it has to be the same
color
are now stage threes all right so the
next video
shows the the last uh
special property of the grills and that
is when you make a shockwave match and
shoot it across
all the peppers on the on the grit on
the grills will go faster okay so you
see that these are all stage ones
we have a five pepper match over here
that's going to make a super shock wave
that goes in both directions
it's going to grow the reds naturally
because that's what's uh you know a
straight line match five always grows
the same peppers are the same color but
we're all we're gonna pay attention to
these ones
and see how they um get grown
as the shockwave passes them on the on
the grill so
go ahead and play that all right so now
we can
pause and look the the
orange stage one that's there is now
stage three so it grew by two stages
and then the um
the red peppers that were stage ones
are now stage threes they were grown by
the shock wave
like all the other ones that are stage
twos on the outside but because they
were on the grates
they grew an extra stage as well so in a
nutshell
the grates the grates grow peppers
faster
they grow them faster than they do on
the outside and they
um they do that for a variety of reasons
so in this level i i queued this one up
because it's kind of the easiest one to
see
and really the first one where i saw how
that
affects the level play um
you can see it a little bit better so
i'm going to go ahead and play through
this a little bit
and what i'm trying to do is explode
yellows on the grates that's what i'm
trying to set up
and um mr claus makes it a little bit
more difficult on this one i wasn't even
paying attention to him there so
that's something you want to do
all right so now now he's going to the
bottom we'll try to work at the top and
bring some yellows onto the board
this will go ahead and do this it'll
clear out that space and set up another
opportunity to make a yellow match
we'll set up uh we could make a match
for going down here but instead what i'm
going to do is
make a match three so i can set up a
match for with the yellows and it's
gonna
he's gonna swipe this pepper so it's
gonna drop down one so when we
you'll see what i mean it'll um the blue
will fall and then
our yellow that we make with our match
four in the next move will be sitting on
the grate
so that's that's much better than just
firing this blue
shockwave down for no apparent reason
all right so he's going to swipe the
blue is going to be there and you see
how
now we can we can explode this blue with
our shock wave
and we're going to be matching a three
and
three ones which is going to drop into
this spot down here after the blue
disappears
so it's going to explode on the great
and now our yellows on the side are all
threes
and same thing here we have a three
dot yellow pepper with two
stage twos and that's going to cause an
explosion and that's going to
grow these even faster now
and as you can see we can count the dots
and we can see that we have
three steaming stage fives and
we got a stage four and one and a one
but because it's a match it's on the
great
it's going to get us our hits on our
statues
so that wouldn't if it wasn't over the
great that wouldn't have caused an
explosion with a six
with six dots but since it was it did
and we got our hits on the statues is
what you're trying to do
so we're going to add this to our guide
on
grills so that you understand exactly
the different things that i went over
here but like i said the main thing to
think keep in mind is that they do grow
peppers quickly
by an extra stage in the in a variety of
different situations the ones that you
want to think about are making a match
on top of it which will accelerate the
growth and cause an explosion faster
shooting shock waves across it which
will increase the growth
and then making explosions on top of
grills which will grow
other peppers of the same color
an extra stage so i hope this helps make
sure you like the video if you found it
helpful
make sure you visit our site for guides
on everything and how the game works
and leave a comment if you have any more
questions and i'll get back to you as
soon as i can
thanks